- Out of all the nominees tonight,
who would you most like to get drunk with?
- [Woman] Oh, wow.
- Who? Good question.
Carell, probably.
- I kind of adore Steve Carell.
I just think he's a
wonderful man and very funny.
- Well, he's not nominated,
but with my husband.
And trust me, we just had
twins like nine weeks ago.
I'm pretty sure that
if we just smell wine,
we're gonna be, like, so drunk.
It's ridiculous.
- Miles Teller.
No, I just feel like
I could give him good,
maybe big brother advice, you know.
I just feel like that would
be giving back, basically.
- Who's, like, the most
conservative of all the nominees,
do you think?
- Bradley doesn't drink,
but I'd drink at him.
- I guess he doesn't really drink,
but Bradley Cooper, I think.
He's a really smart guy,
he's a great actor,
and he's a true artist.
- Michael Keaton.
'Cause I think there's a lot going on
behind those dark glasses.
Yeah, he seems like a lot of fun.
- I actually have.
Clint Eastwood.
- [Reporter] Really?
^ - [Katie] Yes!
- [Katie] That's awesome.
- J.K. Simmons.
- [Reporter] Screaming at you.
- Yeah, I want him to.
- [Reporter] You want him to?
- I totally do.
- Damien Chazelle.
- Julianne Moore.
She'd be fun.
She'd be a lot of fun to talk to.
And then, Iñárritu, of course
'cause there's tequila.
So, I like tequila, so
that works out, too.
- I'd love to see Meryl
slutdropping on the dancefloor.
I would be all about that, yeah.